we don't know if the king is going to
watch this series I can tell either he's
watched previous series of the crown and
you know and enjoyed it I think the last
series
um it was a little too close to the Bone
for him as well Camilla is who I want
that is where my loyalties lie that is
who my priorities I suspect he won't be
watching this I think all of it's going
to make for very uncomfortable viewing
for the king for any member of the royal
family but I do suppose that moment when
she steps out in the Revenge dress I
mean that was just such a low moment for
the royal family Charles admitting
adultery and you know this is the sort
of the war of the Wales is being played
out in in spectacular fashion in the
tabloids and then and then on camera in
in different interviews I think it
probably an awkward moment whether or
not the King James get to see it well we
may never find out the royal family is
in genuine crisis
has Royal scandals damaged the country's
reputation I suspect that even if the
Royals are not watching certainly people
who work at the palace absolutely will
because there's a big curiosity Factor
about this series and it's had so much
media hype that I think it's just going
to make more and more people want to
watch it out of curiosity if nothing
else I think we'll all be watching the
Bashir scenes very very closely and I
suspect the palace lawyers will be
watching those scenes very closely we
now know how Martin Bashir procured that
interview we know how he prayed on
Diana's insecurities and her paranoia
that she was being spied on Prince
William has made it clear he never wants
that interview screened again and the
BBC has promised that it will never be
screened in its entirety so for it to be
reenacted in the crown I suspect out of
everything in all of the plot lines that
was probably one that the Crown's
lawyers were were watching very very
closely and as I say I suspect Palace
lawyers will also be watching very
closely
she opens her mouth and hand grenades
come out she wants to tear down the
temple let's go for it
my dear if Harry's spoken to Dominic
Dominic certainly for Dominic West going
in to that role playing Charles during
some of the most tumultuous years of the
royal family and let's be honest a time
when Charles's popularity was an
absolute Rock Bottom I think any actor
would would jump at the chance because
obviously it's a wonderful opportunity
but probably also think twice about it
as well I mean when they were making the
crown they would have known given the
Queen's age giving her Frailty and that
you know she she wasn't going to live
forever and therefore there was always a
very real risk that this series was
going to go out when she was either
close to death or indeed had died as as
is the case and so I think that is a big
responsibility for the actors for them
it's a role but of course the problem
with all of this is it's not just a role
it's not just a character it's not just
a part it's a real person who now
happens to be king and it is the
dredging up of a past which he'd much
rather move on from
foreign